RIGHT NOW IT IS TIME TO PLAY
@MIDNIGHT NEON SIGN FUN FOR
KICKS!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: UGH.
>> OH, I LIKE THAT.
THE SITE WORLDWIDE INTERWEB.COM
COMPILED A LIST OF NEON SIGN
FAILS, BUT WHAT IF THEY'RE NOT
FAILS.
DID YOU EVER THINK ABOUT THAT
INTERWEBS? NO, MAYBE YOU DON'T.
MAYBE JUST A NAME.
THESE ARE A COLLECTION OF SOME
OF THE BOLDEST AND MOST CREATIVE
NEW SMALL BUSINESSES OUT THERE.
SO COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU 250 POINTS YOU GIVE ME
SLOGAN FOR THE NEW BUSINESS.
HERE WE GO. FIRST ONE. THIS
FULLY AIR CONDITIONED SEMEN.
STEVE.
>> MOM, I AM IN HERE!
>> Chris: POINTS.
NICK.
>> NO SHOES, NO SHIRT, AND WE
WILL (BLEEP) FASTER.
>> Chris: OK GOOD, POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS CHILD LIQUORS.
YES, CHILD LIQUORS.
NICK.
>> NOW ACCEPTING PAPER ROUTE
MONEY.
>> Chris: OH, (BLEEP).
POINTS.
STEVE.
>> FAKE IDs WELCOME.
>> Chris: POINTS. MEGAN.
COME IN TEN TIMES, LOSE CUSTODY
ON THE 11TH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, MILF SELF STORAGE.
MILF SELF STORAGE.
STEVE.
>> WE WILL STORE ANY MILF LIVING
OR DEAD FOR $99.95!.
>> Chris: BUT YOU HAVE TO BRING
IT IN!
>> YOU BRING IT IN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
WAIT ARE YOU SAYING ANY MILF?
>> ANY MILF LIVING OR DEAD,
CHRIS.
>> Chris: WHAT ABOUT SOMEWHERE
INBETWEEN?
>> THAT COUNTS TOO.
>> Chris: MEGAN.
>> YOU DO THE STORAGE, WE WILL
(BLEEP) YOUR MOM.
>> Chris: HEY, POINTS.
GOOD.
NEXT ONE.
BARE FEET HOES, BARE FEET HOES.
>> NICK.
>> BARE FEET HOES, NO SLUTS
ALLOWED.
>> Chris: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> BARE FEET HOES, FOR ALL YOUR
BARE FEET AND WHORE NEEDS.
>> Chris: I DON'T WANT TO BUT
THE AUDIENCE IS MAKING ME GIVE
YOU POINTS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Chris: THE LAST ONE.
LAST ONE.
>> STEVE.
>> POO ENTER, IT IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU THINK IT IS.
>> Chris: POINTS STEVE AGEE.
MEGAN NEURINGER.
>> UNDER POO MANAGEMENT.